[Music]
in wood Tom ooh Kenya the world's
largest spitting cobra has been
discovered at the bio can snake farm the
nine-foot highly poisonous snake
produces a record-breaking amount of
venom feel trying to fit at one of us
I'm actually if you can see I'm holding
him quite gently there but I do want to
be careful named Naja ash after James
ash founder of the bio can snake farm
it's recognised as a new species the
discovery of the giant spitting cobra
makes conservationists concerned about
other snake species that are
undiscovered or lost as habitats
disappear and the environment is
destroyed Roy Taylor director of bio Ken
has been working with snakes here for
years this specimen was collected on
Friday in fact it was on Friday that
through wildlife direct as a platform
and dr. Richard Leakey we were able to
actually tell the whole world about this
species a variety of cobra species are
able to spit their venom over a distance
of several feet the spray is directed at
the eyes of an aggressor so the snake
can escape the venom is extremely
painful eyes must be washed out
immediately with lots of water and if
ignored blindness can occur sometimes no
first-aid is the best first-aid that you
can give this does not mean abandon your
patient and forget about him what it
means is do not tamper with the bite
site no scrubbing or cleaning of the
wound which you would very many cases do
with an animal bite from perhaps a
mammal at vaio can research is conducted
on reptiles specifically snakes and
snake bites to create anti-venom so the
people who work with the production of
anti-venom and with the medical research
work that goes on they in the white
coats they don't want to play with
snakes so that's where we come into it
we will produce that we will get it to
them and then they can do their work
with it bio can is open to the general
public and anyone wanting to learn more
about snakes is well
come for people who are residents and
the local community we allow them to
come in here for your charge the reason
for that is we want them to learn the
difference take so at least that they
can identify and one of the great things
that has happened here in what time
where we are is that the local people
have actually got names for all the
different common species that they have
bio can offers a free remove a snake
service for locals snakes removed from a
property are relocated to the wild or
brought back to the farm for study it's
through research centers like this one
that people can learn to coexist with
animals like these I'm going to put that
back because he really is quite
difficult to hold then give me a hand
take that one back yeah I'm fine I'm
fine let go just grab the door